and so much of the work you're doing is
uh you're
restoring history yeah especially to a
bunch of Christians who have been
brainwashed uh for decades that said I
mean and this is a kind of the
Enlightenment um project was what to say
basically religion causes Wars um super
you know you believe in God you believe
in religion you take religion seriously
look at the Crusades um you're going to
be you're you're going to do you're
going to become violent and then
Crusades quisition you know Etc and so
much of the work you're doing is is say
wait like no that's not the story at all
and that's more of what you're doing in
this book absolutely and um you know you
really that you expressed it well that's
what I've been trying to do these books
sword in simitar this one the new one
I'm trying to offer correctives to
basically generations of fake history
that has been designed to do precisely
what you're saying um and in great
measure to emasculate Christian men
especially by uh convincing them that if
they take up arms in any way way they're
evil they're monstrous evil and then
like you said evil Crusaders etc etc so
I'm trying to show how all that is
actually false and um it's intentionally
so there's this idea and there's this
movement and it's uh subverting the
Christianity in the west and basically
it's I always call it dmat
Christianity they to them the most
approved form of Christianity which you
can be is to be a dmat which is which
begins and ends with turning the other
cheek being tolerant never judgmental
etc etc and I'm trying to show no
historic Christianity had a much more
masculine side if you wish or muscular
side it was robust I'm trying to bring
back the Christianity of the court of
whips and overturn tables type you know
there's that part too that they don't
want you to think is part of
Christianity but without it Christianity
would not even have continued to exist
honestly if you look at the history and
the wars uh that went on and continued
you know in that book I have a great
quote actually you can read I think it's
at the very end from um Teddy Roosevelt
where he says you know if Christians did
not take up take up arms and he mentions
from the very beginning he primarily
focuses on Muslims he says Christianity
would have been snuffed out centuries
ago right so I think there's this kind
of movement to can to disarm Christians
and tell them all you can do is just you
know turn your other cheek and pray and
don't do anything else so where did this
modernist revisionist history begin yeah
that's a good one um well to some
measure I would say with the Protestant
Reformation not from a theological point
of view because a lot of the early
Protestants were big on just War as well
so it wasn't that but it was this kind
of you know it became there so much
animosity for the Catholic church that
anything the Catholic Church did was
wrong therefore the Crusades were wrong
I see and then you know and it's
actually and the Muslims actually became
rehabilitated in the site of Western
Europe because hey if they were fighting
Catholics maybe they weren't so bad
after all you know so I think uh again
that's not a criticism of protestant
theology which is really what matters
it's more of a historical development
from the rift within Christendom right
that's where it begins but I mean that's
again early Protestants didn't have this
issue so I think if you move forward to
today you know a modern Catholic is is
worse than a Protestant from those eras
you see what I'm saying so there's also
this issue with modernity uh that's has
has poisoned uh you know this this sort
of emasculation thing has been going on
for a while you know and it's uh so
would you say like 1700s is maybe where
that narrative yeah you know basically
yeah maybe maybe with the enlightenment
in Vol I don't know you these guys
there's been a strain of this throughout
the history of the church I mean there
there's a there's actually a great book
by a Roman Catholic author called Church
impotent Leon ptal um and he's tracing
the feminization of Christianity from
the Middle Ages on and and I think
there's always been um a Temptation
there a tendency to only want to talk
about the Jesus Meek and mild and and
personal piety and it's sort of a kind
of a feminization of Christianity and he
traces it all the way up to the present
and just notes that there's always been
a some of that and it's relatively rare
um to have Christian Traditions that
have actually been um predominantly
masculine and led by masculine men and
um and so I think that's it's what
you're talking about is something that
the church has faced I think for a long
time right in fact I grappled with this
in the new book that I'm writing because
as a mil the military ORD the first
military order of the Templars that was
a revolutionary concept you're talking
about a religious order that took up
arms and was violent but if you look at
um you know the overwhelming majority of
theologians were on board with it there
was some criticism saying you know H
that's not right but they were really on
the outlier they were just very very
minor I would say today the majority
would be against it right right um but
so yeah that sort of things you find it
popping in and out throughout history
but I would argue that it was actually a
minority uh a very small minority um
interpretation even Augustine himself
was I mean he's usually cited as the
chief articulator of just War Theory
that's right that's right when I
remember I always I always Point people
to Hebrews uh Hebrews 11 is this text of
this you know the this Hall of Faith you
know all these Heroes of the faith going
back to to Noah and Abraham and and
Sarah and others and some were sa in
yeah but but you actually have this I
think a far more holistic picture of um
you know the of what faith does and some
um by faith um went to war routed armies
you know and defended their nation and
won great victories and some by faith
were saw in half were chased into the
into the mountain sides and and died and
but it it it depends on the moment it
depends on the situation it depends on
what you're called to and any number of
details and but both of those can be
faithful you can have you know the the
the martyrs of the church who were
faithful in preaching the gospel and
then gave their lives and shed their
blood in that way and you have men who
went to war and defended their
countryland defended their wives and
daughters and and Sons and that's
faithful too and to the excuse me and
and to the Christians of the time those
who died were Martyrs that's right you
know yes um I think it's also pertinent
to point out and this is something I I
actually got done writing in my book uh
but a lot of modern Christians are
unaware but you know the famous verse
where uh they they say to Jesus uh you
know about swords and they say we have
two you say that that is enough do you
know how that was interpreted understood
historically no most people don't it was
interpreted meant two swords are enough
because one sword is what you will
battle spiritual forces with and one
sword is for secular Warfare yeah that's
how it was understood and uh theologians
of the time that's Norm that's how they
would justify for example the Crusades
so yeah we have one sword to to fight
demons and you know Spirits in high
places Etc right and one sword for kings
and princes to fight evildoers I mean
the idea you know this the sort of
passivity that's attributed to Jesus I
just can't imagine Jesus standing by and
someone's breaking into your house
raping your wife and killing your
children and Jesus is saying no don't do
anything right no how do you I can't no
one in at least historically could
understand that that's what he meant